[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frappe bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse les réactions donc aux résultats
des législatives en Israël pas encore
définitif on le disait à l'instant le
liquide de Benyamin Netanyahou arrive en
tête donc pour l'instant selon les
résultats
provisoires elle insubmercible Benyamin
Netanyahou est-il sur le point de faire
son grand retour d'après le Jérusalem
post l'ex au Premier ministre qui on le
rappelle et poursuivi toujours poursuivi
pour corruption serait en effet tout
près de l'emporter le journal israélien
fait aussi état de la percer de Itamar
bengwir le patron du parti d'extrême
droite haut de sa maillet ou dite force
juive présentée comme le grand gagnant
de ces élections et qui seraient
désormais en position de réclamer les
meilleurs portefeuilles dans le futur
gouvernement selon les sondages à
réaliser à la sortie des urnes
Netanyahou serait en mesure de décrocher
une majorité à la knees 7 et qui indique
également ce matin le quotidien arrête
ce qui évoque un bloc de droite crédité
de 61 ou 62 sièges et un sionisme
religieux devenu le troisième partie
israélien avec 14 à 15 sièges autant
dire une très mauvaise nouvelle pour le
quotidien de gauche qui voit dans la
percée de benzwir les prémices d'une
révolution de droite autoritaire et
religieuse en Israël arrête accuse le
patron de sa maillot dit d'avoir je cite
transformer le projet sioniste en un
projet de suprématie juive raciste dans
l'esprit de son mentor le rabbin raciste
et anti-arabe mère Kane et c'est aussi
le sentiment du dessinateur jordanien
Morad cotcot dont le dessin est publié
par le site cartoon movement qui montre
on le voit un Palestinien assassiné par
un bulletin de vote en faveur de
l'extrême droite
[Musique]
les armes à sang reconnaître la victoire
de l'ulla critique le journal dans le
Brésil de bolsonaro l'histoire se répète
dans l'agitation dans les meute ou
l'aube compare lieu aussi bolsonaro à
Trump mette que le président brésilien
est à la fois plus isolé dans son propre
pays et sur la scène internationale que
son futur ex homologue américain le
discours express de bolsonaro hier elle
a une également du journal de Rio Audi
avec cette juxtaposition assez
accablante à en bas le président sortant
la mine des fêtes est juste au-dessus
cette photo d'habitants de Rio de
carioca qui sont en train de rechercher
de la nourriture au milieu de détritus
des restes jetés là par des commerçants
après l'incendie qui a touché un centre
d'approvisionnement de Rio il y a
maintenant deux jours à noter ce matin
dans la presse française ses révélations
de la présence à l'étranger de plusieurs
bureaux clandestins censés faciliter le
travail des policiers chinois
expliquez-nous l'existence en France
mais aussi au Portugal au Canada et en
Allemagne notamment de ces structures
informelles témoignent des pratiques
extraterritoriales de Pékin dit
pudiquement le monde qui précise que ces
bureaux ont été repérés en septembre
dernier par une ONG de défense des
droits de l'homme qui a donc signalé ces
bureaux de vie informels outre l'absence
d'enregistrement comme représentation
consulaire ce qui inquiète les autorités
en France donc notamment c'est l'usage
qui sera fait de ces annexes pour
rechercher des fugitifs notamment des
wigours mais aussi surveiller la
diaspora et des opposants ainsi que des
chercheurs travaillant sur l'Asie loin
de cette géopolitique sur les trottoirs
de Paris près de 1500 femmes chinoises
vivent quant chaque jour dans la
prostitution libération raconte ce matin
l'histoire de mail une femme de 50 ans
rencontra à Belleville c'est un quartier
populaire de Paris un endroit où elle
dit être arrivé par hasard en 2014 après
quelques années à arpenter les trottoirs
mais il y a décidé de vendre ses
services sur Internet ce qui lui permet
désormais de trouver des clients dans
toute la France en attendant un jour
peut-être dit-elle de trouver de gagner
assez d'argent pour ouvrir un commerce
dans son quartier et puis quelques mots
pour terminer Hélène du rachat de
Twitter par le milliardaire américain
Elon Musk qui n'en finit pas de
provoquer des romans alors que plusieurs
dizaines plusieurs milliers
d'utilisateurs disent avoir quitté le
réseau social de Washington Post enfonce
le clou et ma foi c'est assez cinglant
les amis il est temps de quitter Twitter
le journal qui bilipende aussi bien les
grandes platitudes prophéties par Elon
Musk sur les réseaux sociaux que son
refus éliminer les discours de haine
invite ses lecteurs à aller voir
ailleurs et à laisser je cite les orques
c'est prédateurs marins se battre entre
sur Twitter Elon Musk le nouveau patron
de Twitter qu'on retrouve dans ce dessin
de Chapatte publié par le journal suisse
Le Temps et qui se passe je crois de
commentaires effectivement merci
beaucoup Hélène Hélène Twitter on peut
toujours retrouver en tout cas pour le
moment votre revue de presse qui est
disponible aussi en podcast et sur le
site bien sûr de France 24 à tout à
l'heure